sur le le sujet dont parlait bertan à
savoir cette grève dans l'éducation
nationale est-ce qu'aujourd'hui les
profs l'éducation nationale sont un
problème pour le gouvernement là où
Gabriel hatal avait tenté justement de
de rapprocher en tout cas de se
rapprocher de ses professeurs clairement
oui parce que les représentants de du
personnel les syndicats enseignants ont
tous fait savoir que les conditions
était pas réunis pour que la les
discussions quelle qu'elles soit
puissent avancer avec Amélie casterra et
et et donc la ministre est dans une
situation de de quasi blocage face au
personnel de l'éducation nationale alors
pas forcément face à l'administration
mais en tout cas dans des des
circonstances qui sont particulièrement
handicapantes pour pouvoir mener son
action on a sa feuille de route elle
changera pas même si am wa Castera doit
quitter le gouvernement son successeur
aura la même feuille de route mais là
n'est pas le sujet le sujet c'est la
confiance et le le le type de relation
qui s'est instaurée avec le personnage
an là on voit que c'est une situation
qui est totalement grippée et on se
demande comment elle peut se débloquer
si rien ne change ouais améliie ctera
elle a réduit à néant le travail des 5
mois de Gabriel Atal au ministère de
l'Éducation nationale Michou exactement
oui effectivement d'ailleurs c'est pour
ça qu'il est effectivement très très
remonté hein d'après ce que l'on
comprend quand même contre contre elle
d'autant plus que c'était pas
effectivement son choix donc l'enjeu
aujourd'hui c'est de savoir et on le
saura dans quelques heures siemmanuel
Macron a accepté de lâcher celle qui
voilà qu'il défendait parce qu'il aime
bien défendre l'indéfendable on connaît
hein et que de ce point de vue-là il se
se se rejoint il se résout à être plus
raisonnable peut-être en en séparant
c'est son son super portefeuille en
donnant ou l'éducation ou le sport à
quelqu'un d'autre on verra bien jusqu'où
ça ira mais il est clair que ce qui
vient ce qui émane du terrain et de la
communauté enseignante montre que il y a
pratiquement impossible possibilité pour
elle de pouvoir agir ouais il peut plus
la la la garder c'est c'est devenu
aujourd'hui un trop gros problème Amélie
oua Castera pour ce gouvernement mais si
il pourrait tout à fait la garder c'est
c'est c'est lui qui prendra la décision
et il peut tout à fait avoir comme
argument bah les mêmes que ce qu'on
entend depuis la semaine dernière à
savoir que les choses s'apaiseront que
il va pas se laisser dicter la
composition du gouvernement par Gabriel
Atal puisquon sait que Matignon fait
pression pour que elle s'en aille donc
Emmanuel Macron peut voilà fort de son
autorité présidentielle se dire que et
ben il va pas se laisser avoir par des
mouvements d'opinion et et et des
syndicats de l'éducation nationale qui
lui sont de toute façon hostiles
politiquement il faut souvenir le le cas
du cas de Claude Allègre quand
claudeallègre arrive en 1997 ça ne
rajogit pas au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale il a une formule qui met le
feu à la maison en expliquant qu'il
fallait dégraisser le mammouth cette
formule elle est restée dans l'histoire
on la ressert à toutes les saources mais
mais clauded est resté en place pendant
plus de 2 ans alors que il était dans
une situation de défiance totale de la
part des syndicats de de son ministère
donc Emmanuel Macron a sans doute ça
aussi en tête et peut-être qu'il se dira
que Emmanuel Amélie wacterra peut rester
encore en place bon ça c'est c'est un
élément de l'équation je dis pas que
c'est ça qui va faire sa décision tout
ilement en tête et Gabriel hatal je vous
disais il a de façon assez étonnante
parce qu'on voit rarement ce genre de de
de circonstance aussi CLA euh quand on
fait du du journalisme politique il a
fait savoir par par son entourage que il
souhaitait que Amélie Weda casterra cète
sa place et que elle n'avait pas en
quelque sorte répondu à ses conseils de
ne pas communiquer de ne pas se rendre à
l'école de de faire profil bas et et et
elle elle n'en aurait fait qu'à sa tête
donc il y a un peu en quelque sorte le
le un défi de la part de la ministre qui
a été posé à l'autorité du Premier
ministre en fait vous avez le premier
lui c'est lui moi c'est moi entre Atal
et ma et Macron à propos de la mise de
l'éducation donc on verra si d'abord
comment ça se termine et puis on verra
quelle trace ça laissera dans la
relation entre les deux mais il est vrai
que c'est quand même un peu un peu
étonnant de voir qu'il pourrait y avoir
une volonté de du président de la
République de de de se cramponn à la
cette nomination de d'amélier UD Castera
pour des tas de raisons que l'on peut
imaginer euh au dépend de l'intérêt de
l'école et des enjeux et de la gravité
donc des des dossiers à régler mais
puisque vous parlez du lui c'est lui moi
c'est moi est-ce que cette décision ça
dira quelque chose de la relation àal
Macron et et de de la marge que peut
avoir Gabriel Attal vis-à-vis d'Emmanuel
Macron en tout cas ça montre la volonté
pour l'instant et on on verra une fois
de plus quelle sera la décision finale
mais mais ce ce ce bras de fer en
coulisse qui n'est pas une ni voilà une
rupture en quoi que ce soit ni ni une
tension réelle mais en tout cas
là-dessus c'est ça permet à gabrielal de
dire je ne suis pas simplement un
collaborateur tel queon l' beaucoup
présenté et et ça permet àmanuel Macron
aussi dans l'état de dire c'est c'est
moi le patron donc la question
maintenant est savoir comment cette ce
sujet va se régler est-ce qu'un troisème
un trème voilà Laron qui surgit depuis
depuis 24 Hees va peut-être permettre
voilà de déclarer d'apaiser ou de régler
différents je ne sais pas avant de
parler du du trème L est-ce que ça dira
beaucoup de quel premier ministre peut
être Gabriel hatal de la décision qui va
sortir concernant amoude Castera non je
suis pas sûr parce
que on est tous dans le myth du chef du
gouvernement parce que c'est son titre
officiel pour le locataire de Matignon
et on imagine enfin en tout cas
l'opinion peut s'imaginer parfois que
c'est comme un chef d'équipe ou un
manager dans une entreprise et et autour
de lui il y aurait des des des salariés
qui même si c'est des salariés de haut
niveau qui seraiit à ses ordres mais ça
fonctionne pas du tout comme ça un
gouvernement il y a certes un premier
ministre vers lequel remonent des
arbitrages très techniques ministère par
ministère quand il y a des des conflits
mais en en ce qui concerne le le portage
politique la posture politique et le
discours chaque ministre est totalement
indépendant et on Nimagine pas du tout
Gabriel hatal aller expliquer par
exemple arfid hadti ou éc DUP Moretti ce
qu'ils doivent dire comment ils doivent
penser et quelles décisions ils doivent
prendre au sein de leur propre ministère
ça peut arriver quand il y a des cas de
conflit par exemple quand Bery veut des
économies un un ministère s'y oppose et
à ce momentl et a un arbitrage comme on
dit dans le jargon qui remonte à
Matignon mais pour le reste au quotidien
les les ministres Emmanuel Macron a
voulu qu'il a des ministres qui qui a de
la personnalité de la carrure la
capacité à aller porter le le fer dans
les débats bah ces ministres là ils vont
suivre leur propre cheminement et et
leur propre volonté de de d'action
politique donc le le fait que il y ait
des arbitrages qui soient pas forcément
rendus favorablement pour Gabriel Atal
vis-à-vis de de l'élyisée oui ça
arrivera nécessairement donc mais il
faut pas h forcément les interpréter
comme des crises politiques ça ça sera
au cas par cas qu'on en jugera oui ça
effectivement je ni tout à fait raison
euh avec N moins un contrôle général de
de de la part du secrétaire général de
l'Élysée d'Alexis coller qui évidemment
lui est en surplomb est en panoptique
sur toutes les tous les fonctionnements
de toutes les administrations et de tous
les ministères et bien souvent on a
aussi il y a aussi des injections de de
et impulsion de de de d'arbitrage
d'éléments de langage de positionnement
vis-à-vis donc des des ministères
concernés ce qu'on appelle les fameuses
commandes de l'Élysée ou du matin au
soir un ministre un ministère se se
retrouve avec des mesures à élaborer
parfois en 24 heures parce que c'est
décidé là-haut bon ça c'est aussi la 5e
République on sait aussi que quand même
tout se décide dans un bureau on l'a
bien vu à à main à main exemples alors
on va parler du trème Laron François
Baayou dont le nom revient depuis 24
heures et ça relaxe dans l'affaire des
assistants parlementaires européens du
model est-ce que si vous êtes Gabriel
Attal vous avez politiquement à perdre
ou à gagner à avoir François Baayou dans
un gouvernement
euh dans ces cas-là c'est une manière
aussi pour Gabriel Atal de de montrer
une forme de je dirais de de hauteur de
vue de mensuétude peut-être de pardon
des offenses ça lui permettra de montrer
voilà qu'il est capable donc de dépasser
et de faire prévaloir un intérêt
politique peut-être ça ça permettra
d'avoir une carte dans une négociation
euh euh voilà liée à son remanement euh
en tout cas les messages qui parlent de
matinon depuis hier font dans ce sens
hein voilà Gabriel tal dit fait savoir
qu'il n'y a pas de problème avec avec
François Baayou du côté des des proches
François Baayou il disent aussi mais
enfin il y a jamais eu aucun problème
bon ok on a compris c'est c'est
opération apaisement parce
qu'effectivement il est très
certainement probable qu'il faut
permettre à François berou de de revenir
au gouvernement après 2017 c'est une
sorte opération mont Cristo hein pour
lui sauf qu' on a quand même sorti chez
Gabriel Atal la volonté de garder la
main sur l'éducation nationale en allant
à matinnon est-ce que c'est possible
avec un François Baayou à la tête du
ministère é bah c'est c'est peut-être la
raison pour laquelle ils se rencontrent
et de voir un peu dans quelle mesure ils
peuvent fonctionner ensemble et quel
serait le le modusind le mode opératoire
la manière dont un échange de loyauté
mutuelle je pense que c'est François
Baayou il s'y
entend en évolution politique donc de ce
point de vue-là je pense qu'il est en
train de capter ce qu'il doit voilà
accrocher avec aussi Gabriel Atal qui
représente l'avenir et justement Gabriel
Atal qui qui représente l'avenir est-ce
que politiquement il a gagné à faire
rentrer un un un François Baayou qui est
là dans la vie politique depuis de
nombreuses années François Baayou vaut
mieux l'avoir avec soi contre soi malgré
tout on a vu les tensions qu'il y a eu
au moment de du vote de la loi
immigration où une partie des députés
modemes était prête à voter contre
finalement c'est'est abstenu mais bon il
y a eu quand même un sujet on a à
l'Assemblée nationale toujours des
députés modem qui sont capables d'aller
porter des des amendements contre la vie
du gouvernement défendre des idées je
pense notamment à celle de de Jean-Paul
Matthis sur la fiscalité le président du
groupe qui ne plaise pas du tout à
l'exécutif et donc il a eu voilà une
capacité entre guillemets de nuisance en
tout cas de peser à l'Assemblée
nationale qui que le le gouvernement ne
peut et Emmanuel Macron ne peuvent
absolument pas négliger mais on peut
dire la même chose des députés horizon
donc pour Gabriel Atal le fait
d'intégrer si tel est le cas si si parce
que pour l'instant on a juste cette
hypothèse mais ça n'est pas une
information confirmée si tel est le cas
et et et François Baayou qui rentrerait
au gouvernement à ce moment-là pour
Gabriel Atal ça lui fait on va dire un
atout de plus dans sa manche parce que
c'est une personnalité politique qui qui
a suffisamment de poids et d'expérience
et et l'envie toujours d'en découdre euh
et bien dans dans dans ce gouvernement
ça fait une personnalité politique qui
va pouvoir aller débattre et puis
essayer de de rapprocher parce que c'est
quand même l'objectif qui lu a été fixé
de de rapprocher la liste Renaissance
aux élections européennes de celle du du
rassemblement national qui fait la
course en tête loin devant à ce stade
ouais c'est ça l'intérêt Michel c'est
que d'un côté vous faites rentrer une
personnalité qui est peut-être pas la
plus simple politiquement gérée mais de
l'autre côté vous achetez un peu la
loyauté du MoDem oui et puis vous
continuez à à montrer que cette ce
dépassement ce ce ce courant central
raisonnable même d'quun dirait chez eux
continue à être vivace continue à être
animé et cette fois-ci un un un binôme
un binôme possible on verra Atal beayou
représenterait effectivement cette cette
cette pérennité et donc effectivement un
enjeu important pour il y a un argument
important dans le scrutin qui se prépare
alors l'autre question qui se pose c'est
il y aura-t-il d'autres débauchages chez
les républicains après celui de Rachid
hadti on va écouter ce que pense de tout
ça David lissnard le maire les
républicains de Cann le problème c'est
que ça détruit la confiance quand il y a
une telle incohérence
entre une critique extrême virulente de
de l'exécutif et et tout d'un coup dire
je me sens bien avec cet
exécutif les les les Français dont je
suis qui regardent ça se disent mais la
vie politique c'est ça ça doit pas être
ça c'est qu'à un moment donné moi
j'aurait aimé qu'on dise écoutez je
nomme rachidti elle accepte parce que
voilà sur le plan culturel on va enfin
avoir une vraie politique culturelle la
France va enfin redevenir une puissance
culturelle est ce qu'elle n'est plus VO
là on entend il était l'invité ce matin
de la matinale d' LCI évidemment David
Lisnard critiquaé ces débauchag est-ce
que de nouveaux débauchages peuvent
avoir lieu du côté des républicains ou
est-ce que le Vivier est épuisé Nicolas
non il semble que il y a une en tout cas
a une recherche de ministre chez les
républicains y compris au Sénat parce
que la mission avait été donnée par par
Emmanuel Macron de voilà de sonder les
candidats potentiels pour rentrer au
gouvernement donc on aura peut-être
effectivement de de nouveaux noms de de
républicains qui vont se joindre à ceux
de de Rashid hadti et des ex
républicains qui font déjà partie de de
l'exécutif ou qui sont depuis 2017 et
forcément on entend dans la bouche de de
David lner Ben cette amertume cette
incompréhension on a un parti politique
les républicains qui aujourd'hui est
dirigé s'oriente de plus en plus sur une
ligne de droite radicale évidemment ça
ne plaît pas à tout le monde au sein du
parti il y a des gens qui auraient pu
faire partie de l'aventure en marche
déjà il y a quelques années qui n'y sont
toujours pas qui sont restés dans leur
parti par par loyauté mais qui sont en
désaccord total avec cette ligne de
droite radical et qui peut-être se
disent que bah l'avenir c'est ce n'est
plus les républicains mais ça sera un un
un un noyau central qui penche au
centre- droit et qui leur convient bien
ou on entend effectivement comme disit
Nicolas l'amertume de David lisn est-ce
que c acte 2 du gouvernement peut être
l'occasion d'affaiblir encore un peu
plus les républicains oui d'ailleurs
c'est l'objectif et dans dans cette
découpe évolution à la découpe de LR on
va assister à la dernière tranche
jusqu'en 2027 c'est-à-dire oui bien sûr
beaucoup font leurs calcul vont voit que
il n'y a pas de possibilité aujourd'hui
pour l'air de de de rassembler de
redevenir majoritaire et de reprendre le
pouvoir en tant que tel donc cette
fameuse poutre qui avait été désignée
par Édouard Philippe continue encore à
travailler et oui bien sûr on va aller
de plus en plus vers cette cette sission
qui n'est qui qui n'est pas une sission
du parti mais une sission politique
entre ceux qui n'acceptent pas l'option
radicale et ceux qui vont ont vocation à
rejoindre entre ce ce qu'ils estiment
être le centre droit et leur leur
famille politique d'origine cette
annonce elle aura lieu aujourd'hui
Nicolas
écoutez plein d'infos plein
d'infos bon on verra le suspense peut
peut encore durer aujourd'hui a lieu
évidemment cet hommage national aux
victimes des attaques du Hamas en Israël
c'était le le 7 octobre dernier hommage
national mais il y a quand même une
polémique St on va voir ça avec vous
polémique autour de de la présence de la
France insoumise certaines familles de
victimes ne veulent pas voir les
insoumis à cet hommage oui elles se sont
tourné solennellement vers Emmanuel
Macron pour lui demander de barrer la
route aux insoumis elles ont envoyé un
courrier au chef de l'État on peut lire
la chose suivante nous famille des
victimes des terroristes du Hamas
demandons solennellement à ce que soit
interdite toute présence de la France
insoumise à l'hommage national qui sera
rendu aux 42 victimes Franco israélienne
du 7 octobre c'est signé de la main du
collectif no silence un collectif qui
représente plus famill de victimes qui
revendique plusieurs centaines de
militants se dit féministes et
humanistes donc plutôt classé à gauche
Orian et qu'est-ce qui est précisément
reproché à la France insoumise mais
l'attitude de ces leaders depuis le le 7
octobre on se rappelle de la sortie de
la députée Daniel obono qui quelques
jours après l'attaque avait qualifié le
Hamas de groupe de résistance depuis il
y a eu plusieurs sorties de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon des propos des députés
Mathilde Panau Thomas porte David
guireud qui on s'en rappelle avait dit
le bébé dans le four c'est Israël hier
lors des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement le député LR des Français
de l'étranger meer Habib a demandé au
gouvernement de ne pas inviter les
député LFI à l'hommage aux Invalides
écoutez la réponse de la partte de
parole du
gouvernement si le protocole prévoit
d'inviter tous les responsables
politiques chacun chacun appréciera
l'opportunité ou non de sa présence
puisque les familles se sont exprimés je
tiens ici une nouvelle fois à dire que
justifier le terrorisme c'est accepté
qu'il frappe à nouveau et ça décourage
pas et la France insoumise oui il faut
peut-être mettre à part François Ruffin
qui sur France interrière déclare la
chose suivante les parents qui pleurent
leurs enfants ont tous les droits fin de
citation le député de laomme ne
participe pas à l'hommage aux victimes
du 7 octobre contrairement à certains de
ses camarades
écoutz nous avons été invités à cet
hommage national par le Président de la
République et je veux dire ici
solennellement que les polémiques
doivent s'arrêter quand la nation tout
tout entière rend hommage aux morts
rappelez-vous dans son blog Jean-Luc
Mélenchon avait théorisé sa volonté de
tout conflictualiser cette cérémonie
aura peut-être été l'occasion
d'illustrer une nouvelle fois cette
doctrineou quel est le sens de la
présence de la France insoumise on
entend Mathilde de Panau est-ce que le
math Panau pardon est-ce que leur
présence est opportune aujourd'hui il
s'appelle plutôt les impolis ou les
indignes ça c'est c'est évident on sent
bien qu'effectivement cette théorisation
de du bruit et de la fureur
va trouver aujourd'hui une nouvelle
expression dans cette présence qui est
une tout simplement une provocation
politique C c'est évident parce qu'on a
bien vu on a compris on connaît on sait
très bien à quel point il y a eu un
refus de un entêtement de de qualifier
le Hamas de terroriste de qualifier ce
qui s'est passé effectivement le le 7
octobre et toutes les toutes les
déclarations de résistance avec avec le
Hamas donc c'est c'est les choses sont
absolument claires on est est quand même
sur une grande hypocrisie le le les
insoumis avaient refusé de participer
soi-disant à la marche contre
l'antisémitisme parce que le le RN était
présent mais là ça ne posera aucun
problème d'être dans la cour des
Invalides au côté des des élus du RN
donc on est sur une grande hypocrisie
une volonté de provoquer et au fond les
familles vont éprouver vont être va
avoir une épreuve supplémentaire au cœur
de leur épreuve il y aura une autre
épreuve supplémentaire le protocole
républicain à bondeo oui cette situation
elle met la France insoumise dans une
incohérence totale vous venez de
l'expliquer parfaitement entre les
message qu'elle a voulu faire passer à
partir du du 7 octobre et même déjà
avant sur voilà un relativisme
complètement abject et et et sa présence
aujourd'hui effectivement c'est
totalement incohérent mais ça permet
d'en parler ça permet de le souligner et
peut-être peut-être parce que c'est ça
qu'il faut avoir c'est cet espoir de
faire progresser les consciences y
compris au sein de la France insoumise
et c'est tout l'enjeu de de de de de de
ce qui'est la République et si les
insoumis ont été invités c'est parce
qu'ils sont des élus de la République et
donc en tant que tel ils ont à assumer
ce qui'est la République ce qu'elle
représente quelles sont ses valeurs euh
y compris l'humanisme qu'ils prétendent
revendiquer eux-mêmes et bien
aujourd'hui ils sont devant leur
conscience ils onuront leur conscience
face à eux ils vont être devant les
familles des victimes qui vont les
regarder droit dans les yeux
et espérons rêvons que ça les fasse
progresser que ça fasse comprendre et
que quelque part et bien il soit dans un
un chemin de de voilà d'apaisement et et
et peut-être de de de critique on verra
bien n'allons pas soyons n'espérons
peut-être pas trop mais en tout cas
c'est important que dans le dans un
moment républicain et bien tout le monde
soit mis face à ses responsabilités et à
sa conscience en tout cas le signal
politique a été capté par François
Ruffin qui lui se saisit de ce moment
encore un autre mais celui-ci quand même
assez serti je dire assez visible pour
se démarquer euh pour continuer son
travail de rupture vis-à-vis donc de la
doxa générale de LFI et de de de
Jean-Luc Mélenchon parce
qu'effectivement il a été le seul à dire
voilà les les familles ont tous les
droits les familles qui ont qui pleurent
leur mort ont tous les droits euh c'est
une manère une fois de plus cette
fracture qu'il y a alors
fris sûr absolument il y a deux Frances
insoumises il y a ceux qui qui se
réunissent régulièrement qui sont les
les frondeurs de Mélenchon enfin ceux
qui ont été purgés surtout par par par
Manuel bonpard sur ordre de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon les anciens compagnons de
route hein euh donc les garideau hatin
Corbière qui n'osent pas quand même
aujourd'hui encore faire l'acte
politique majeur peut-être vont-ils
attendre les européenne peut-être
ont-ils un calendrier certainement mais
on sent bien qu'il y a cette volonté là
et François Ruffin lui matérialise dès
qu'il le peut il le fait encore
aujourd'hui et quelque part c'est
peut-être lui qui qui sauve qui sauve
l'honneur euh parce que c'était encore
possible mais euh les quant au reste des
troupes et des des insoumis ils sont
effectivement et incohérent et indigne
et impoli en revanche aucune
interrogation aucune polémique sur la
présence du rassemblement national
est-ce que rien que ça c'est une
victoire de Marine Le Pen oui bien sûr
parce que une époque il y a pas si
longtemps le rassemblement national et
et et son leader et son fondateur le
fondateur du Front national avait des
propos antisémites et qui ont été
condamnés comme tel euh Jean-Marie Le
Pen qui euh a toujours eu voilà des
positions critiquant euh et critiquant
Israël et les Juifs et là euh Marine Le
Pen a a effectivement opéré un
changement politique majeur euh pour se
normaliser en quelque sorte
euh donc leur présence aujourd'hui au
regard de ce qu'est leur histoire elle
est effectivement particulièrement
significative de ce qui est devenu ce ce
parti et la façon dont il a manœuvré
pour essayer de faire oublier ses
origines
oui eu il s'est passé aussi quelque
chose avec euh au moment de la marche
contre l'antisémitisme qui était une
initiative républicaine he qui n'avait
rien à voir avec ce qui se passait en
tout cas en référence avec ce qui se
passait au ProcheOrient et là Marine Le
Pen a au fond prononcé une phrase
politique elle qui va qui qui va la
suivre longtemps en disant je suis là où
je dois être euh et c'est une sorte de
phrase en hub qui est à la fois destinée
à Emmanuel Macron à à au au au
responsables de l'Assemblée nationale à
son électorat au Juif de France il y
avait quand même un message global à
travers cette phrase là et qui a
effectivement marqué la profonde
mutation de de SP Pary dans la vie
politique française on verra après
ensuite avec quel résultat et quelle
Capac quelle efficacité mais pour
l'instant c'est quand même très net et
et on est sur une logique inversée avec
une partie de de de la gauche de
l'extrême gauche dont les a soumis il
faut quand même souligner un point c'est
que en dépit de ces postures parce qu'on
peut continuer de les appeler des
postures euh on voit dans les au sein
des électorats que c'est des sondages
qui sont fait sur des propositions qui
sont des propositions antisémites est-ce
que vous êtes d'accord pas d'accord on
teste des différents items et on voit
que la proportion d'antisémitisme ou
dité d'antisémitisme est toujours
beaucoup plus largement diffusée à
l'extrême droite qu'à l'extrême gauche
même si à l'extrême gauche atint des
niveaux significatifs donc il y a
peut-être de la part des leaders
politiques des des des mouvements qui
qui sentre croise en ce moment mais en
tout cas au sein des électorats le mal
persiste assez largement
merci merci à tous les deux on regarde
ensemble ce qui a la une de nos
quotidiens régionaux c'est avec
[Musique]
Steve et à la une de la presse régionale
ce matin si le pas de calis qui est à
nouveau en vigilance orange oui risque
de pluie et d'inondation pour le
département des cumules allant de 20 à
40 mm sont attendus ce mercredi ça fait
la Une de nordéclair aujourd'hui qui
fait le point sur les dégâts des
intempér de ces derniers mois une
dizaine de maisons sont encore menacées
d'effondrement dans la vallée de la 1 la
Cour des comptes s'en mêle oui et ça ne
plaît pas à tout le monde dans le
Dauphiné ce matin on revient sur un
rapport accablant sur les stations de
ski la Cour des comptes estime que seul
quelques sites en France peuvent espérer
poursuivre une exploitation au-delà de
2050 pourquoi et bien parce que la
majorité d'entre elles n'auraient pas
suffisamment pris la mesure du
réchauffement climatique dans le
daofupfinet on peut lire des
professionnels qui ne sont pas du tout
du tout d'accord avec cette analyse
attention la pollution dans le gare
c'est la Une de Midi Libre une usine
chimique située à saint-lindre est
pointée du doigt des analyses montrent
des taux alarmants d'acide très
corrosifs dans l'eau autour de cette
usine eau de surface mais aussi eau
potable une association accuse les
autorités locales d'inaction et promet
des poursuites en justice des nouvelles
dans la lutte contre le trafic de drogue
oui aucun territoire n'est plus épargné
par la drogue titre choc de la montagne
ce matin le journal écrit que ce n'est
plus seulement l'affaire des grandes
villes dans le puit d'au même les
territoires ruraux sont désormais
impactés par le trafic et la
consommation de stupéfiants reportage à
lire dans la commune de tier où des
fusillades en éclaté à l'automne les
habitants sont toujours très marqués par
ces événements en partie lié au trafic
de stup on va en charante en charante on
fait plus d'enfants bon il y a pas qu'en
charante il y a pas qu'en charante en
tout cas le nombre de naissance en
charante a reculé de 20 % en 10 ans
charante libre fait sa Une sur le
phénomène il nous dit que l'enfant
unique fait des petits la charante vous
l'avez dit n'est pas un cas isolé c'est
une tendance que l'on retrouve au niveau
national selon le journal la cause est
notamment à rechercher du côté d'un
avenir de plus en plus incertain pour
les jeunes parent et ceci explique
peut-être cela je vous vois venir je
venir auian sud-ouest nous rappelle
comment on fait les bébés aujourd'hui la
grff du sexe titre le quotidien qui
revient sur cette étude étonnante la
fréquence de l'activité sexuelle des
français est en berne 43 % affirme avoir
un rapport par semaine en 2009 ils
étaient 58 % le taux d' activité
sexuelle des Français et ça est à son
niveau le plus bas depuis
1970 moralité si vous ne le faites pas
pour vous Orian faites-le pour la France
il faut réarmer démographiquement la
France c'est ce qu' a dit le chef de
l'État vous en souvz c'était début
janvierou c'est ça non on voit que vous
avez vous avez bien retenu vous avez
bien retenu le message étap étap dans
quelques années merci Steve Nicolas dans
la tribune dimanche quelques petites
infos si vous en avez on parlera
nécessairement de des du remanement qui
s'annonce voilà quand on verra bien et
puis on vous parlera aussi des réseaux
sociaux et notamment des dangers
particuliers auquel sont exposés les les
enfants ça sera à lire dimanche dans la
tribune dimanche merci beaucoup Nicolas
Prisset merci beaucoup Michel d'mon
d'avoir été avec nous merci Steve merci
à tous de nous avoir suivi prochain
rendez-vous à 15h la séance de question
d'actualité au Gouvernement au Sénat et
puis à 18h Thas h sens public et nous on
se retrouve demain très bonne
journée I